the 2017 SP awards were a Grand Slam for
cute couples who slayed the red carpet
with serious style and adorable PDA plus
a sweet friendship for the ages
[Music]
we spend together on and off for ten
years and and now we have a beautiful
son together and and you know we are
very happy Michael Phelps couldn't help
but gush over his wife Nicole who he met
10 years ago at the ESPYs the former
beauty queen dazzled in a tight navy
gown and a stunning diamond necklace a
very very fun night tonight's her
birthday so we'll have a good night
Stephanie and Ayesha curry smoldered in
their ensembles the 28 year old
lifestyle expert flaunted her fit figure
in a sparkly jumpsuit while the Golden
State Warriors star looked dapper in all
black man John Cena and Nikki Bella
shared a smooch while posing for photos
together the WWE diva looked hot in an
athletic number that showed off her
toned abs it's crazy during the show
John presented fifteen-year-old Jarius
Robertson with the Jimmy V award for
perseverance he's been battling a rare
liver disease for most of his life but
backstage with et it was all jokes and
smiles you think if you tried to steal
Nikki Bella from him you could do it
yeah pretty much
thank you for being gracious enough not
to do that
[Music]